you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
today's episode is going to be something
a little bit different Intel approached
me and asked me to talk about the
concept and application of neural
networks to tie in with their Intel
Nvidia snura compute stick first we're
going to cover what the device actually
is and then we're gonna dig a bit deeper
into newer networks and what they're
useful so let's begin so what is the
Intel Nvidia snura compute stick it's a
compact device not much bigger than a
standard USB drive that plugs into a
computer through USB 3 port it enables
rapid prototyping validation and
development of deep neural network
interface applications and it doesn't
require users to connect to the cloud
it's basically Hardware designed to run
certain types of AI systems super
efficiently ok so let's back up for a
minute and explored a neural network
actually is in simple terms a neural
network is an algorithm based on the
principles of machine learning so what
is machine learning it's the ability for
a computer program or AI to gradually
learn by experience towards a goal
established by the human programmer for
instance if you wanted to train an AI to
tell the difference between a cat and
the dog you start with the basic
parameters then you have it built test
it then take the top-performing models
rebuild and fine-tune from there this
process happens over and over again
ultimately generating what we consider
more intelligent algorithms after
thousands of iterations this process
generates artificial neurons otherwise
known as nodes which are connection
points of data each of these nodes
consists of an equation and have an
input and an output the nodes are
arranged in layers that all together
make up the neural network what's really
fascinating about neural networks is
that there's so many of these
connections and they're so elaborate
that the original program is aren't
entirely sure about how they come about
or what they even mean the end result is
an algorithm that can learn things
recognize patterns and make decisions in
a human way and it doesn't have to be
programmed to learn explicitly it learns
by itself just like a brain
and even more staggering since 2012 the
general complexity of neural networks
has increased 500 times when a neural
network is formed it can do highly
specialized tasks such as the previous
simple example of a cat vs. dog sorter
this is an application known as visual
processing the development of generating
a neural network is known as the
training phase and involves vast amounts
of data after this phase the neural
network needs to be tested in real-world
applications to see how it responds in
real-time and if it works as desired
traditionally you'd need to connect to a
cloud service to do this but what if
there's another way this is where the
Intel Nvidia snura computer comes in
what's fascinating about this device is
that you can gain on device deep neural
network capabilities without using much
power in fact as I mentioned before this
is considered a low power device which
is pretty cool because in most scenarios
you'd be utilizing massive server farms
Intel's new your computer stick has a
specialized onboard hardware visual
processing unit capable of more than 100
gigaflops of performance within a 1 watt
power envelope the interim of phidias
computer stick can calculate the vast
amounts of data required in a neural
network without having to connect to the
cloud or even be online this equates to
an increase in privacy and reliability
and it means whatever you're working on
stays local and mobile there are fewer
variables inherent with working local
and also keeps things running smoother
so that you can troubleshoot quicker
since you eliminate some of the bigger
potential factors right away so Intel's
neural computing doesn't replace the
traditional style of the neural network
there what it does is fill a need on a
more basic level essentially closing the
gap between massive and expensive
networks and more experimental projects
for example me and my friend had a
little go at running a neural network
that allows hand-painted art styles to
be transferred to photos
lastly the low-power nature of the Intel
neural compute stick opens up even more
doors yes it conserves energy but more
important than that it means compact
consumer devices can benefit from new
types of a I powered applications areas
like virtual and mixed reality drones
robotics and security systems basically
its neural network competing on the go
at all likeliest is powerful and it
becomes more so when paired with Intel's
neural compute as DK so if you'd like to
know more about Intel AI I've included
some links in the description below
anyway that's all for this video if you
know someone who would be interested in
this feel free to pass it along to them
leave a comment in the description and
tell me what you think about neural
networks this has been to gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion I'll
see you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
and you thinking
[Music]
you